dr mark siegel now fox news contributor
professor of medicine at nyu langone
medical center so uh doctor i'm going to
start with with the obvious um it is a
little disingenuous
if not flat out something else for this
administration to tell us that they
didn't know this was coming in time to
at least get a handle on testing because
we know from the south african president
and then today from the who world health
organization that at least
by thanksgiving
we knew the 25th of november some
reports that it might have been earlier
than that your thoughts
you know yesterday harris good afternoon
good morning i just spoke yesterday to
dr wassila gillard josat and she's the
public health specialist at the national
institute of communicable diseases in
south africa who's been
very vocal about this for weeks and
weeks and she told me look this this
this virus this variant is
multiple times more contagious than
delta and she says that prior infection
appears to play a role in slowing it
down and giving you a milder case as
does the vaccine here's the point this
information has been available for weeks
and south africa reported on it
yesterday they put out the study that
proved it that if you're not vaccinated
your chances of dying are much higher
but it isn't just vaccine it's also
having had prior infection we knew about
this we've been tracking this our own
cdc has been tracking this i talked to
dr wolinski about this weeks ago we knew
variants were emerging from areas like
africa and india we've we knew this we
knew they're going to be more
transmissible because that's what a
virus does to survive disingenuous is
the right word harris it's the right
word what we have here is a lack of
preparation
a lack of preparation so apparently when
you point that out it hurts yesterday
the president snapped at a reporter for
asking about
failed failure on testing rather let's
watch
what's your message to americans who are
trying to get tested now and who are not
able to get tested and who are wondering
what took so long to ramp up testing
come on what took so long if i told you
four weeks ago that this would spread by
a day-to-day basis
it would spread by 50 100 200 500 i
think you would have looked to me and
said biden what are you drinking
but that's what it did
wow that tone you got to save that for
commander the new puppy
an op-ed in the new york post calling
biden's claim that omicron was somehow
unforeseeable quote total bull
it reads once omicron was detected in
the fourth week of november the world
went bananas precisely because it was
going to spread rapidly
and the president's claim directly
contradicted one of his own top covet
advisors here's that
this pace um the speed uh by which
omicron has
been you know transmitting has been seen
and mirrored in many other countries
and so this is exactly what we
anticipated is the administration behind
the curve on
being prepared to ship about 500 million
free home tests when we need them now
yeah
well we're going to hopefully quickly
catch up with that curve
you know where else it's obvious
where all those americans are waiting
for hours in line to get a test and can
rarely find them anywhere in their
communities
dr siegel
listen michael minnow from harvard has
been talking about this for months and
i've been on the show with you weeks and
weeks and weeks ago talking about how we
needed rapid tests in every home in
america everyone's heard me say that and
i'm not alone and the way that the rapid
tests occur in every home is the federal
government being ahead of this with a
public-private partnership pre-ordering
to the companies like abbott like
quiddle and getting this to happen 500
billion doses
a test shows they can do it but they're
talking january here harris and then
you've got to go to that federal website
where you're probably going to be
waiting for an hour trying to log on
right that's ridiculous we need billions
of tests we need them now especially
with a widely spreading variant that
everyone could have predicted you can't
get a test and all there is is panic and
that's what contributes to it
well a lot of people are trying to
travel and if you're going to check into
a hotel
no matter where you are if you're going
to get on a plane you're going to need
to have a negative test and in many
cases regardless of whether you are
vaccinated
or unvaccinated so if that's the case
now because it's the holiday season
you're competing with far more many
people than just might be curious or
feeling a little bit sick and want to
know if they have covid the world is
getting ready to travel they're already
into it
doctor let's move to this this big
development today the fda is reportedly
set as early as today to authorize covid
treatment pills both from pfizer and
merck you've been telling us about this
you said this is a game changer
bloomberg is reporting that the two
drugs are seen as promising new oral
treatments that can be taken upon onset
of symptoms to help prevent
hospitalizations and deaths dr siegel
this moves the ball
yeah i'm going to go on record right now
and tell you that the pfizer drug is
much better than the merck drug they're
very similar to drugs we used for hiv in
years ago in the 90s and the pfizer drug
is a protease inhibitor that changed the
game for hiv and it looks really good
here and it was just published in the
new england journal of medicine
decreases your risk of hospitalization
by 90 percent if we diagnose you early
again rapid test in your home you don't
go roaming around looking in a pharmacy
somewhere rapid test positive the pill
packs lovid decreases your risk of a
severe outcome whether you're vaccinated
or not this is the game changer they've
been sitting on it now the question is
okay fda is going to approve it this
week harris but they only pre-purchased
10 million 10 million doses we need not
10 million 100 million 100 million
yeah but there are 330 million plus
americans
uh and and look not everybody's going to
need them but you you want a big
stockpile all right last question for
you with where we we are right now
you've got the testing that's behind you
know and it's got to catch up you've got
a variant that looks like from what
south africa and the uk are reporting
could begin to level off and then you've
got some new drugs how long does it take
to get those things in place that really
make a difference we've got the fda but
when will they be available through your
doctor
it's not going to be for weeks until
it's geared up and let's talk also about
the monoclonal antibodies
right gsk makes a monoclonal antibody
that we need now not not today not
yesterday we need it
this moment we need the pill we need the
monoclonal antibodies we need the
testing right now and you're absolutely
right in south africa it's leveled off
but a lot of people are affected one
last thing get get the boosters out
there now but not by luxury i completely
agree with that with what you said
earlier let's not demonize people let's
not mandate people let's talk to people
and let's get those shots into doctor's
offices which you and i have been saying
also for weeks let me have that
conversation let me have that
conversation not a politician
if you're having a conversation with
your doctor it only makes sense and the
federal government might have to help
out
to have enough people to handle that
on-site for doctors but do whatever it
takes
real quickly the army has come up with
what could be
something that can hit all the variants
they say they have a single vaccine to
guard against most covid and sars
variants but a caveat here it was not
tested on the omicron variant dr siegel
what's your take on this
you know i'm glad you brought this up
because i want to point out something
that you and i both love which is the
military we haven't even talked about
this their infectious disease division
both at walter reed and at u.s
amrit armory
infectious diseases is top of the world
they're as good as the cdc or better and
they've been quietly researching a
vaccine that uses a soccer ball type
protein hasn't been tested against
omicron but has been very effective
against all variants still in early
trials but this may be the game changer
for the vaccine where you just need this
vaccine and you don't have to keep can
reconfiguring for emerging variants this
research very exciting still early going
into middle stage trials now with humans
walter reed you mentioned it and the
military is critical we'll keep an eye
on this part of the our coverage dr
siegel thank you very much a lot going
on thank you today hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now